coping mechanisms and advice for
screenwriters going through development
hell oh my goodness get to the end of
the script as you can cut it out
afterwards but get to the end get the
finish I mean I do go they call it how
for a reason when you're like working
with other people and you're in
development hell what that means to me
is that you're having creative
differences with the people you're
working with and already having like a
different vision of the movie you're
trying to make I think that's why its
development how perhaps also because
it's stalling because you're trying to
attach people maybe dad said but if it's
if it's actually about the script I
think one of the most important things
and it depends what kind of film you're
working on if it's if it's like your
heart if the script is something that's
from your heart and that's really yours
if it's not working with the people
you're working with find other people to
work with if it's not right then and
you're in development yeah and it's
he'll get out and find a different way
to make your movie you know if it's if
it's your movie it's different if if
it's you know you're you're a writer for
higher on something and you know and
it's not but then it's not your heart
and then it shouldn't be your hell is
there he'll you know so then you you
know like you let you know then I think
you have to do is practice happy
detachment you know and really deliver
what the people who are paying your
bills want and need and let go of your
own ego and deliver what they want yeah
but if it's your heart if you if it's
your film something that you've written
and you love and you find yourself in a
situation in development that the people
you're working with are not you know on
the same page as you I would find a way
to get the hell out of that because it's
not gonna get easier making a movie with
somebody it's like okay we're like as we
are married it's too much it's a
marriage two years of your life and
people say it's yet you're gonna be
working with them for you know some
problem or two years longer possibly
more and more than that you're gonna go
through so much and really if you don't
have I think it's so important when you
start out with somebody like if you're
looking for somebody to collaborate with
on your movie it's just so important to
find the right people to
do it with and the right people are not
necessarily the most experienced and
then not necessarily you know the ones
with the fanciest offices or the ones
with the most money that's not
necessarily the right people to make
your movie with the right people are the
ones who really share your vision of the
movie and I mean that creatively I mean
that also in the sense of what the movie
will be after it's finished you know
like that you have similar goals that
you share values just like getting
married to somebody you know you're
going to have a happy marriage if you
share values and you share certain goals
and you want the same things and you're
not going to happen happy marriage if
you don't and if you are in that
situation with a film you know it can be
as miserable as a bad marriage so it's
and it's not worth that you know so I
sort of like if it if there's
development how like coping strategies
other than like yoga every morning and
meditation you know I'd like really like
just you know like this happening yes
absolutely you know like those are all
good coping strategies but I also like
to be honest if it's really bad at the
beginning try to find a way to get out
of it yeah cuz it's not going to get
better yeah because it gets
progressively more and more tumultuous
the further down the road you go why
because I other people's agendas start
to bleed into your your ideas and your
creative work and what everybody said
they were getting on board for at the
beginning changes and when they start to
see either success or failure then they
start to detach or attach themselves to
it right and so then they try to enforce
their will upon your initial ideas and
so if it's not working at the beginning
it's not going to work it's at the end
it's going to be ugly and I mean
filmmaking is hard you know like there's
no there's no way around it when you're
actually and not just the shoot you know
I mean shoot so hard but shoots are also
fun because there's a lot of people
around you know it's a long process and
there's always challenges and there's
always going to be unexpected things you
know and there's always going to be very
difficult things and if you are doing it
with people that you have
you know that you're solid and tight
with that can still be fun even with all
the challenges but if you're not if you
know when when things get difficult and
you're not in the same page it's going
to be a thousand times worse mm-hmm
you